let's say we were to take a little
excursion to the moon and so here we are
sitting on the surface of the moon
that's the surface of the Moon right
there and with us to our excursion to
the moon we brought two things we
brought ourself a concrete brick so
that's my brick right over there
that's my concrete brick all that's
orange all it will say it's an orange
concrete brick and I also brought a bird
feather with us so this is the bird
feather so this is the bird feather and
then my question to you is if I were to
hold both of the brick and the bird
feather at the same time and I were to
let go of both of them at the same time
and ask you which one of them would hit
the surface of the Moon first what would
you say well if you base it on your
experience on earth on earth if you were
to take a brick and a feather a brick
would fall which just goes straight down
a brick would just immediately fall to
the earth and it would do it quite
quickly it would accelerate quite
quickly while a feather would kind of
float around if you had a feather on on
earth on earth it would just kind of you
know float around it would go that way
then would go that way and it would make
it would slowly make its way down to the
ground so on earth at least in the
presence of air it looks like the brick
will hit the ground first but what would
happen at the moon and what's
interesting about the moon is we have no
atmosphere we have no air to kind of
provide resistance for either the brick
or the feather so what do you think is
going to happen so your first temptation
would say well let's just use the let's
just use the law the universal law of
gravity so what is the force of gravity
on the brick so the force on the brick
well you could calculate that out the
force of gravity on the brick is going
to be equal to big G is going to be
equal to big G times the mass of the
moon I'll say the that's an M for mass
and then the subscript is lowercase M
for moon the mass of the moon times the
mass of the brick times the mass of the
brick divided by divided by the distance
between
the brick and the center of the Moon
squared so this is the distance between
the brick and the center of the Moon and
you square it fair enough that's the
force on the brick what's going to be
the force on the feather the force due
to gravity on the feather or another way
to think about it the weight of the
feather on the moon so what is the force
on the feather we'll do the same
calculation the force on the feather the
force on the feather is going to be
equal to big G big G times the mass of
the moon times the mass of the feather
times the mass of the feather divided by
the distance between the center of this
feather and the center of the Moon
squared that's the distance and then we
squared so if you look at both of these
if you look at both of these expressions
they both have this quantity right over
here G times the mass of the moon
divided by the distance between this
height and the center of the Moon
squared so they both have this exact
expression on it so let's replace that
expression let's just call that the
gravitational field on the moon so if
you apply this number by any mass it'll
tell you the weight of that object on
the moon or the gravitational force
acting downward on that object on the
moon so this is the gravitational field
of the moon so I'll just call it G sub M
and all it is is all of these quantities
combined so if we simplify it that way
the force on the brick due to the moon
is going to be equal to that lowercase G
on the moon normally we use this
lowercase G for the gravitational
constant on earth or the for the
gravitational field on earth or
sometimes the acceleration of gravity on
earth but now we're referring to the
moon that's why this lowercase subscript
M is doing for us so it's equal to that
times the mass of the brick for the case
of the feather the force on the feather
is equal to all of this business so
that's the G sub M is equal to G sub M
times the mass of the feather times the
mass of the feather
so now assuming that the mass of the
brick is much greater than the mass of
the feather so let's we're going to
assume which is a reasonable thing to
assume that the mass of
the brick is greater than the mass of
the feather then the mass of the feather
what's going to be their relative forces
well here you have a greater mass times
the same quantity here you have a less a
smaller mass times the same quantity so
if the mass of the brick is greater than
the mass of the feather it's completely
reasonable to say that the force of
gravity on the brick is going to be
greater than the force of gravity on the
feather so if you do all of this and
everything we've done to this point is
correct you might say hey there's going
to be more force due to gravity on the
brick and that's why the brick will be
accelerated down more quickly but what
you need to remember is if there is more
force that's being gravitational force
on this brick but it also has greater
mass and we remember the larger
something's mass is the more the larger
its mass the less acceleration little
experience for a given force so what
really determines how quickly either of
these things will fall is their
accelerations and let's figure out their
accelerations so we know that we know
that I'll just in a neutral color we
know that force is equal to mass times
acceleration so if we want to figure out
the acceleration of the brick or we
could write it the other way the
acceleration if we divide both sides by
mass we get acceleration is equal to
force divided by mass acceleration is
equal to force divided by force divided
by mass and acceleration is a vector
quantity and force is also a vector
quantity and in this situation we will
we will use we will use well I'll use a
well we're not using any actual value so
but if I were using actual values I
would use negative numbers for downwards
and positive values for upwards but
we're not using any signs here so but
you could assume that the the direction
is implicitly being given so what's the
acceleration of the brick the
acceleration of of the brick it's a
lowercase P I was writing the
acceleration of the brick is going to be
equal to the force applied to the brick
the force applied to the brick which is
the force applied to the brick divided
by the mass of the brick but the force
applied to the brick we already know is
this business right over here it is
little G on the moon the gravitational
field on the moon
times the mass of the brick and we're
dividing that by the mass of the brick
so the acceleration on the brick on the
moon or the acceleration that the brick
will experience is is the same thing as
that gravitational field expression it
is G sub M is that this is how quickly
it would accelerate on the moon now
let's do the same thing for the feather
and think you see where this is going
the acceleration of the feather the
acceleration of the feather is going to
be the force on the feather the force on
the feather divided by the mass of the
feather the force on the feather is G
sub M G with the subscript M times the
mass of the feather times the mass of
the feather and then we're going to
divide that by the mass of the feather
and so once again its acceleration is
going to be the same quantity so they
are both going to accelerate at the same
rate downwards which tells us that
they'll both hit the ground at the same
rate they'll both accelerate from the
same point at the same time and they'll
both have the same velocity when they
hit the ground and they'll both hit it
at the exact same time despite one
having a larger mass so the reality is
is the larger mass does create a larger
gravitational or because it has a larger
mass it has a larger gravitational
attraction to the moon but because of
its mass that attraction gives it the
same acceleration as something with a
smaller mass so any mass at the same
level on the surface of the moon would
experience the same acceleration so now
you're the quite natural question is
wait Sal if that's true on the moon it
should also be true on earth and it
would be true on earth if you did this
exact same experiment and you evacuated
all the air from the room so that you
didn't have air resistance and you took
a brick and a feather and let them go at
the same time they will both hit the
ground at the exact same time which is
little on too unintuitive to imagine a
feather just plummeting the same way a
brick would but it would if you
evacuated all the air and so the answer
with what the reason why we see this
over here and I think you get the sense
because I already talked about
evacuating the air is that the
difference between the brick and the
feather is all due to air resistance if
you took the same brick or if you took
something that had the same mass as the
brick and you were to flatten it out
it has more air resistance so if you
were to flatten it out if you were to
flatten it out but let's say it has the
same mass let's say this thing and this
thing have the same mass this thing
would fall slower than that because
it'll have more air resistance it has
more air to kind of collide into to
provide resistance as it falls and if
you took a feather and if you compacted
it really really really really really
small the same mass as a feather but you
made it so small that could kind of cut
through the air you'll see that it will
drop a lot drop a lot faster so the real
difference between how things fall on
earth if you had no air they would all
fall at the exact same rate it's only
because of air that they fall at
different rates and the air does two
things for constant pressure so if you
have two objects that have the same
shape the object that is heavier that
has more weight will fall faster because
it'll overcome it'll be able to it'll
provide more net force against the air
pressure if you have something that has
the same weight the object that is more
aerodynamic will fall faster the one
that cuts through the one that has the
least air resistance and it's a little
experiment that you can try in the
comfort of your own room right now take
a brick or not a brick take a book take
a book take a book like this and you
could drop it and then you could take
another piece of paper or even a little
you know postcard or something and you
drop it and you'll see of course a
postcard will fall much lower than this
book but what you do is put the postcard
on top of the book so that the book is
essentially breaking all the air
resistance for the postcard and what
you'll see is if you put it on top of
the book and you were to drop it you'll
see that they followed the exact same
rate